hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es wild berry Cupcake
ja sieht gut aus ne
[Musik]
das sind für mich wild berry Cupcakes
der Sommer ist da und deswegen wird es
Zeit für Cocktails ob sie jetzt mit
Alkohol oder ohne Alkohol sind
entscheidet ihr selbst ich habe mir
jedenfalls gedacht dass die Cocktails
mich dazu inspirieren Cupcakes draus zu
machen ihr könnt natürlich auch Kuchen
machen und Torten machen aber Cupcakes
sind so ideal die kann man nämlich auch
perfekt Teilen heute gibt's
weil es einfach cool ist und weil es
bestimmt lecker schmeckt ich mache sie
allerdings Anti alkoholisch ihr könnt
aber gerne später noch ein bisschen Lily
dazu geben ich sag euch am besten
einfach an welcher Stelle jetzt backen
wir erstmal den Muffin dafür verwendet
ihr 150 g Zucker eine Prise Salz 200 g
Mehl plus Backpulver oder ihr nehmt
einfach mein backmehl da ist alles schon
enthalten zwei Eier 150 g Sonnenblumenöl
150 g Buttermilch und etwas
Vanilleextrakt natürlich dürft ihr hier
an dieser Stelle auch gerne ein bisschen
die Lee verwenden dann habt ihr auch
schon mal bisschen Lilly Geschmack im
Teig der Alkohol verfliegt dann auch ihr
könnt aber auch später einfach den
fertig gebackenen Muffin nehmen und
damit trinken dann habt ihr es noch mit
dabei entscheidet einfach selbst ich
nehme jetzt hier einfach die trockenen
Zutaten und berühre sie in einer
Rührschüssel nehme die flüssigen Zutaten
und verrühren Sie auch in einer Richtung
und dann wird beides einfach nur noch
miteinander vermischt
[Musik]
wenn ihr beide Zutaten verrührt habt
sieht der Teig so aus und dann nehmt ihr
euch einen Eisportionierer und
portioniert das ganze direkt in die
Muffinform und die Muffins können
gebacken werden
während die Muffins noch backen kann ich
schon mal die Fruchtfüllung zubereiten
dafür verwende ich 300 Gramm gemischte
Früchte 50 g Wasser 40 g Zucker 5g Acker
Acker das ist pflanzliches Geliermittel
etwas Zitronensaft und Vanilleextrakt
die Zutaten kommen jetzt hier einfach in
den Topf werden miteinander verrührt und
aufgekocht für etwa 2 Minuten
und jetzt am besten die Früchte mit
einem Pürierstab durch pürieren und dann
aufkochen lassen und zwei Minuten lang
sprudelt kochen
und jetzt die wildberry Masse umfüllen
und gut abkühlen lassen
die Muffins sind abgekühlt und auch das
Fruchtpüree abgekühlt jetzt geht es
direkt an die Creme dafür verwende ich
auch ein bisschen was von meinem
abgekühlten Fruchtpüree nämlich ein 120
Gramm Fruchtpüree 250 g Mascarpone 60 g
Puderzucker 400 g Sahne und etwas San
apart zum steif schlagen jetzt verrührt
ihr zuerst den Mascarpone mit dem
Fruchtpüree und gebt den Puderzucker mit
dazu alles gut einrühren jetzt die Sahne
aufgießen und mit seiner paar steif
schlagen
[Musik]
die Creme habe ich jetzt in den
Kühlschrank gestellt jetzt sind die
Muffins an der Reihe ihr nehmt am besten
einen Apfel entkerne oder auch gerne
einen Ausstecher oder ein Messer und
höhlt hier die Mitte aus den Deckel aber
aufbewahren das Zwischenstück das dürft
ihr auch gerne naschen
das machen wir sozusagen Platz für die
whiteberry Füllung
jetzt kommt hier die Füllung rein
es geht am besten mit der Dosierflasche
da seid eben nur fertig jetzt noch den
kleinen Deckel wieder drauf geben
zack zack und jetzt könnt ihr wenn ihr
wollt die Cupcakes gerne mit Lilly ein
bisschen bestreichen oder ein Lilly mit
drauf kippen der Muffin ist zwar so
schon richtig saftig aber wenn ihr wollt
dass es ein richtiger Cocktail wird dann
jetzt mit dazu
die Creme völlig jetzt in einen
Spritzbeutel ein mit einer großen Sterne
und dann werden die Cupcakes dekoriert
wenn ihr die Creme etwas pinkfarbene
haben wollt gebt ihr noch bisschen
Zitronensaft dazu denn die Blaubeeren
die geben so ein schönes lila und wenn
ihr aber so ein bisschen pinkiger das
haben wollt pinker ist das Adjektiv ab
jetzt schon dann einfach ein bisschen
Zitrone dazu die Säure macht das dann
jetzt den Spritzbeutel schön senkrecht
halten und die Cupcakes damit spritzen
[Musik]
das sind für mich wild berry Cupcakes da
noch die Früchte drauf
[Musik]
so sehen die Cupcakes jetzt aus und da
müssen jetzt natürlich noch die wilden
berries drauf the Wild Berries sucht
euch einfach aus was ihr gerne habt ich
nehme Erdbeeren Blaubeeren
Johannisbeeren und Himbeeren und ich
hole noch draußen aus meinem Garten
kleine Wald Erdbeeren die sind nämlich
richtig wild
[Musik]
fliegen wie bei Marvel ich habe Hunger
also nee ich mir alles vom Befehl
und zwar mein wild berry Cupcake der
sieht richtig richtig gut aus
den werde ich jetzt bei euch probieren
das habe ich gewartet deswegen Kamera
und jetzt ist passiert
das passiert halt
wenn man meint um die
um die Ecke anzugaben hier sieht gut aus
ne
schmeckt super auch ohne lillet
hervorragendes Rezept probiert es gerne
aus ihr findet es auf sallys-blog.de
oder natürlich in meiner kostenlosen App
wenn ihr wollt dass wir generell die
Kategorie Cocktail Cupcakes einführen
ich könnte ja mal wenn er einladen drei
Cocktails nein drei Cupcakes die ballern
dann schreibt gerne in die Kommentare
denn mir fallen noch 10 tausende
Cocktail Cupcakes ein also macht's gut
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss